I can't quite believe that three years
ago I began my life as a youtuber with
this video explaining that I had become
disillusioned with filmmaking,
my major at school,
and wanted to become a novelist.
The plan back then was to follow the
example of John Green,
who is just then finishing the fault in
our stars because morning it's Monday.
The vlogs purpose was to find an
audience for a novel I had written while
living in Paris and hoped at some point
to publish.
A couple of weeks later,
I came up with the name.
Here's my thinking.
I'm an editor and a writer and they're
fighting writer,
a nerd writer these days.
Youtube is like the wild west of media,
and even the ones who've made it can't
quite conceive of their profession
because whenever they started doing what
they're doing,
it didn't exist.
At least that's been the experience for
me.
Early on.
I knew that what I was doing here as the
nerd writer was more exciting and
fulfilling than any other work in my
life,
but exactly what it was alluded.
So today,
now,
three years later,
I want to update the mission statement
of this project.
What we do here besides talk with our
hands a lot,
is cultivate worldview.
I think those two words sum it up
nicely.
Worldview is,
as you know,
a particular philosophy of life.
It implies the entirety of what we
comprehend and believe about the world,
about ourselves,
about how each interacts with the other.
It suggests a commitment,
a modest one to the well rounded
individual,
the intellectual life we at the nerd
writer are men and women of letters.
As Taran said,
nothing human is foreign to us.
We recognize that life is philosophical,
moral,
political,
financial,
psychological,
artistic,
scientific,
and that what is worth knowing is worth
weaving into a complex and comprehensive
web.
That's what goes on here at the nerd
writer and it's a process that takes
time.
I researched right film and edit this
project by myself and the free time I
have after working a full time day job,
but my dream is to do this with you full
time.
I've set up an account on Patrion.com
and today I'm asking for your help to
keep this project going.
If you don't know what Patrion is,
it's a really cool way for fans to
become patrons of the content they love.
The way it works is like this.
When you become a patron of an artist,
you're agreeing to give that artist a
tip.
Every time they release a piece of
content.
For the nerd writer,
what you can expect is three to four
videos a month,
maximum four,
so if you pledge $1,
say that means you're going to be
spending somewhere between three to $4 a
month.
It's important to note that the nerd
writer will always be free.
You will always be able to access this
channel and the videos here without
charge.
This is just for people who have the
ability and the desire to help support
this channel.
I don't want anyone stretching their
budgets if they can't afford it.
For those of you who donate $1,
you'll get a text mention at the end of
all my following videos.
For those of you who donate $3,
you'll get a personal type written poem
by me sent to your house.
For those of you who donate $5,
and this is by far my favorite.
You can get a limited edition nerd
writer Mug at matches the Mug logo at
the beginning of my videos or other perk
ideas.
I want to know what you think they're
for you.
So I think she'd probably have a say in
what they are giving me suggestions in
the comments here at the nerd writer.
We think and speak critically
dispassionately,
precisely as we can.
We try to see the world and ourselves
for what they are.
We try to think about how we would like
them to be and why it is we would like
them to be that way and we think about
thinking to hear we cultivate worldview
and have had a fucking good time doing
it.
So thank you.
And coffee on a Tuesday.